hijab interviewing trans hijabi
was he right was he wrong
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro is picky to the 90s
moshino
dear friends welcome back to my channel
before i start one of the prayers that
was supernatural the most merciful the
most trust or praise is glory and
gratitude
belong to him so brother says i want to
get straight into it
hijab interviewing trans hijabi
was he right was he wrong we're going to
discuss this inshallah because there's
some
there was a youtube video a youtube
video made
there was tweets i'm going to discuss
all of this from different brothers et
cetera and
i don't believe they're coming from a
place of harm or evil et cetera and i'm
good with the brothers you know but what
you want to discuss so we can have a
common understanding most of the times
these
things happen because of
miscommunication misunderstanding
and when you talk to you're like ah i
understand
so and i had a telephone discussion as
well with uh ustad farid may allah we
had a nice discussion
uh maybe we had some uh agree agree to
disagree moments
but we we said look i understand we
understand both each other etc we talk
about brothers
now a couple of um years ago me and musa
had now went to
birmingham he was invited by a sister to
go to the house
obviously her mom was present dad wasn't
there and that that
her brother was okay he he said that he
was homosexual
and he had a boyfriend so obviously they
didn't know what to do the mom's crying
obviously he was upset
um and um the daughter was upset because
he and her mom upset and that upset us
all so we wanted to speak to him he came
down when he saw us he ran back out
ran back up now he left the fold of
islam
now the question is this now we might
see the act of homosexuality
as disgusting we might say you know what
is absolutely wrong
the question is the following just
because you see something to be wrong
to be disgusting to be evil to be a sin
to be whatever does that mean
that the person who's carrying out the
act that we start being evil to them and
harsh towards them and show our disgust
would that
work we need to have wisdom allah
subhanahu wa
and that indeed if he was harsh with
them they would have run away from you
so allah saying don't be harsh when
allah said muslim
to one who claims to be a god when allah
told the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him if he was harsh with who
the quraish were committing shirk
billion times worse than homosexuality i
know sexuality is wrong as well that's
not the
other oh that's better it's wrong as
well islamically we believe this to be
wrong
now in these instances are two prophets
once we know them to be
speak you know in good nice tone to the
mushriks
and one has been sent to somebody who
claims to be god one is worshiping idols
one is claiming to be
god to be an illah and muslim has been
told
to go and speak to him with words of
wisdom and gentleness
yes muslim became a bit firm after
realizing what he dealt with but that is
not what we're saying brothers and
sisters
so acknowledging that we need to
understand that
that is our dawah is not limited to
okay you can only give bow to the
mukmins you know like these um
super salafi uh uh minded
yeah they're the attitude towards the
muslims only
you give thou only to the people across
you yeah yeah yeah
this time you don't go near them etc
this
weird thinking process so the question
is this
was it right or was it wrong for hijab
let's get straight into it
now brothers and sisters hijab is a
brother to me
is close i talk to him yeah we talk to
regular we do something we'll train
together
we talk we go eat together et cetera i
have a principle imagine if i have
turned my back against certain family
members because of islam
because of the truth of the hack i'm not
going to hide that hack because
somebody's my friend
and if if i've done it with family
members in the context where i've not
that i've turned my back but like you
know
said them this is wrong and i've been
boycotted or etcetera whatever stuff
i've been going through
i don't care i want to make something
great i used to work with a brother you
guys know
yeah and i have nothing but love for the
brother yeah because i want to make that
conversation this for a purpose
and me who started many brothers for
years advised the brother and advised
him private and private and private
why because it's important for us to
advise in private
it's very important and many years we
try to until we realize the damage
that's been caused to the tawa
and the youth and even certain actions
causing certain people to leave islam
was too much for us to turn a blind eye
and i had a lot to lose regard god
besides losing a close brother
and friendship and being kind of
boycotted
maybe they didn't mean to or whatever
that's how i felt
and there was other things that i lost
which i can't get into yeah
and it was at stake but i didn't care
and i don't care
because if it's the hack i don't care if
you're my dad and my granddad my
great-granddad
the hack is the haqq yeah speak the
truth even if it's against yourself
allah subhanahu talaha tells us
so i want to make something for them i'm
in a job i'm not a yes man
if i was a yes man i would have stayed
with certain other brothers or worked
with certain other individuals
i'm not a yes man muhammad if he's wrong
i'll tell him he's wrong
like i will tell him i don't care if
hijab gets angry or upset or
i don't care i want to make that clear i
don't
like tiptoe around here driving oh
brother if he's wrong i will come and
tell him you're wrong and there's been
times where i've told him i'm sorry i
may be wrong here
you're absolutely wrong so the thing is
and it's the same attitude with me
yeah that's how we are but in this very
instance i don't find what was wrong
i don't understand a certain brother is
tweeting
twitter and he's making it seem
like we are these american apologetics
which we like yeah homosexuals
transgender yeah we love you
nice just because hijab is polite to
somebody
how does that i don't get it so you
can't be polite now
you can't be reasonable you're talking
to a 17 year old person who's
become a transgender what do you want us
to do
insult him shut up you're discussing
your evil you're finished you're going
to the fire
this what you want us to say dawah is
done with wisdom and hikmah
and because hijab is speaking to him to
a certain tone he becomes wrong now
oh you should have you should have been
more harsh why
can we not speak with respect in a
civilized manner to someone and hijab
after this discussion the very same
person made the tweet saying
i look stupid i wish i never went on
there
well i think that was the point of what
hijab was doing
in the context of yes he wanted to speak
to him i don't think he wanted to make
him look stupid
but he wanted to show some contradicting
statements
so if hijab is doing that brothers and
sisters what i'm trying to understand is
the following
i learned a lot from that the way they
have conducted himself
the arguments that he used and so many
people in the comment section were
saying
at least you're equipped with it you
can't just brush it under the carpet
just because it
looks urged you and er doesn't mean that
it is
not something that should be addressed
yeah you might not stomach it and not
like it well okay
that doesn't mean we have to stop our
dawah just because you seem something
hajib
and oh in our country we never so sorry
we're not in your country
yeah i mean we can't come and make it
seem like someone's doing wrong because
it looks wrong to you
oh why you speaking like imagine i'm
speaking to someone who has intimacy
with the piano
but i'm not going to be like okay we
don't talk to him yeah just totally
disregard him
now regarding okay giving him platform
i believe when the guy didn't have a
nostril but had he was not a threat
he has no platform let's be real the guy
doesn't have a platform so
giving him a platform like what do we
mean like if there is somebody
who has doubt shabbat the guy is
throwing doubt
are you giving a platform we understand
this is somebody who's chose to change
their gender and it's all
more emotional and this is how i feel
and this is a you can see that from his
statements
how is that person afraid i don't
understand how is that person afraid
no now if your issue is with the style
of dawah well i'm so sorry you can't
have a go at somebody
publicly in the dawah scene you're going
public
because of his style oh you should have
been more harsh you should not have him
on there
that's your opinion was it haram for him
to have him on there
was it hard on no so then would it
from for him to speak to him in a decent
way while dealing with his arguments
no so then it's not me having a god and
saying oh you
i don't like your style of dawah it's
it's not fair
now another thing for example i watched
uh
brother saget youtube as well um and i
know it's coming from a place
of like a good place but one thing i
disagreed was like yes hijab has made
mistakes
yeah with the whole uh yasaka interview
etcetera
mistake in the context of what we know
how the quran is preserved well we have
no doubt
somebody who's not qualified in the
field they're like uh yes
he's not qualified that's not his area
it's not his expertise yeah i can be an
expert in uh i can be
you know construction this doesn't mean
i'm gonna be an expert in the field of
uh
i don't know thermodynamics or whatever
it might be yeah okay
just because you have a field expertise
here doesn't mean you're an expert
everywhere
so that was wrong in the context of i
would say that specific thing should
have not been done
but hijab is interviewing people and he
is kind of debunking this behind and
he's a different people in his podcast
he's interviewing them yeah now
to equate that and see a few mistakes
for example certain things that he made
and then add this into it's not fair
because what you're doing is saying okay
hijab was wrong here
hijab was also wrong here and this
transitive thing it looks ur to me and
it's wrong to me
therefore ah add this to the list that's
not fair
that's not fair you might be right in
the first and the second you can see
that it was wrong here
you should not done that okay we
understand you let's advise the brother
in private
is hijab that much of a liability no
it's not so to go out
doing a public video i believe it was
unfair it was wrong and especially with
people that we know
you've got my number brother call me
let's talk it's not fair
and then to add this trance hijabi thing
which nothing was done
and he was he dealt with that so much so
the very guy himself admitted that
i was wrong you know i looked stupid so
to me i don't understand why is that
fair to now add that to the list and be
like oh i see hijab did it again that's
not fair
that's not fair to say or hijab did it
again because he didn't do it again
so and and i love these words for saying
all of them
nothing but love but i'm seeing the
going out public what it does is it
causes some kind of disunity
now this this unit doesn't mean like you
know some people say
we work with everybody brother if i was
working with everybody i would not start
working with certain brothers
yeah that debunked the very claim that i
stopped working with brothers i'm not
explaining i don't work with
everybody here the point is this
unnecessary disunity
because a lot of people saying come on
was this needed yeah
and how does it look outside to the
enemies of islam how did you do
now you're doing you're bringing back
old things that were done are you
bringing it and adding this on top like
your job did something wrong
with the issue of transition you have a
right to disagree and say i would have
not
you would have not or you would have
have a different tone with them does not
make hijab
wrong so please bothers when
like what i'm just saying is when we're
doing these things look you might you
have a right to disagree hundred percent
i'm not seeing
you guys don't you dare no please
contact me
or whoever i'm just saying hijab aki
that was wrong you know maybe you
shouldn't have done that
let's discuss let's talk we're open
we're not look we are open we
make mistakes i've made mistakes people
have advised me in private yeah
i've changed those like things that i've
seen but for
people close to me nothing hurts me more
in the context of
if i'm doing outright battle go out and
refute me
but if i'm not doing something that's
outright biting
then the thing is you've got my number
you can contact me
one night a lot of people call me all
kind of stuff here here this
but people that are close to me i'm not
brother you got my number for example
yeah
you can call me let's talk let's discuss
you might be right you have a point
but to bring this and we're talking
about hikmah and wisdom
and then and then we're bringing it to
the public
well it doesn't need to be there because
hijab is not a liability
to certain context he's not so brothers
and sisters what i'm just saying is in
in a nutshell i believe what he did was
right it's a growing problem
this whole transgender thing is a
growing massive
problem that had to be dealt with
brothers and sisters
so that's the reason why i'm saying if
you want us to just dig
under the carpet until it starts to
stink and smell and then we're like okay
let's talk about it now
well we've got a lot of poo to clean up
now so the thing is brothers and sisters
i'm just seeing um and like i said
before like prophet sajid and brother
fareed
um and the rest like all i'm saying is
look we know you're coming from a place
of good but please
talk to us because it doesn't show this
unity and some issues going on etc
it's unneeded we'll lie to us issue like
this hijab has a discussion in the park
with trancy jabbies
i mean transgender he spoke to them
what's the difference he spoke to these
people and he's debunked their points
all he's done is the same thing with a
muslim trans hijabi yeah
okay and so what we're just saying this
is to reach out to these people when
we're doing the dawah
and also to make them understand so they
don't feel excommunicated
and be like okay i'm gay transgender
this is how i'm going to be treated
i'm leaving the form of islam is that
good should make sure we get them to
leave islam as well
if we can keep them in the food of islam
we will
and for people thinking no you have to
be harsh it's better i'm so sorry bring
me evidence from the quran and the
sunnah
that it is haram for us to dialogue with
them
um to talk to them in a decent manner
yeah in a decent manner if we
please bring evidence yeah okay in a
decent manner and
um that it's that it's haram for us to
help
get them to stay as a muslim even though
they're committing a major sin
please if not then these issues native
attack called yeah i believe if a child
came and said to me i'm gonna i'm gonna
finish off this if a job came and said
to me
i'm gonna interview a guy who has
intimacy with an animal with a dog
yeah i would say look personally is it a
growing problem
no not really i better not touch but if
it's a growing problem where you're
having a massive amount of people having
intimacy with animals
yeah i'm like well talking debunking
bobby and
i'm trying to say so the the thing is
yes
one thing is that we need it's important
for us to speak to our elders as well
how i've covered everything brother and
sisters and i think it's let's be fair
inshallah in that context and i'm not
saying
brothers are not i know they come from a
place of good but please
with this stuff it should be out the
public there's a lot of stuff that i
just with a job i speak them in private
all the time i will carry on speaking
the hijab in private if i believe he's
done something wrong and the same with
him if he believes i've done something
wrong
to the point where i believe or he
believes i'm a liability ali tao is an
outright misguided individual who needs
to be publicly
brother sisters this person is wrong
alidawah is wrong he's wrong
but there's no such case there's no such
case
so inshallah let's assume the best in
our brothers
let's understand this is where we was
coming from hope you guys understand
because we we deal with it on the ground
level we see the destruction it poses
and these people are leaving islam
because they're feeling unwanted that
shouldn't be the case
i'm so sorry if our kindness is going to
keep them in islam
while we speak the hack not yeah
transgender
yes gay brilliant nobody said that
so that's it bro and sisters until next
time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh please do
comment section below and give me your
feedback
if i'm wrong i might be wrong just i'm
open to
that's it goodbye